foreign
[Music]
[Music]
try that
[Music]
you didn't
when the cops get here you have to be
good and gone I can't help you anymore I
know it's not your fault you were born
this way
you ate them I believed you had to I
don't know why
I thought I was the only one
I don't want to hurt anybody famous last
words
I don't actually
why'd you happen to bring me along
you seem nice I am nice
okay I'm looking for you I smelled you
you could smell me half a mile away
can you do that not that far I got rules
never never ever eat an eater
I thought you might be hungry for hands
no he lives here is there someone dead
up there
[Music]
I'm not gonna be like that we don't have
many options
after you eat you off yourself or you
lock yourself up in there we're
dangerous one of us chicks teach me how
to smell other eaters but we can hurt
one another just as bad
it's too much
you gotta do this we have to do it
you've been following me and we got
unfinished business
you know I'm thinking of a bad person
[Music]
all I think is that I love you
[Music]